Hello, and very excited to talk about share flaws between the Julia programming language and EMAX.
While Julia and EMAX look like different pieces of software, I think there is profound
commonalities between the two. Let's start by introducing Julia.
Julia is a high-level dynamic programming language. Julia is free and opens her software
and is used primarily for scientific computing. The reason Julia is used for scientific
computing is that while Julia is high-level and has a syntax like Python or MATLAB,
Julia can be high-performance. I use it to develop climate models that run on hundreds of
GPUs. Models are traditionally developed with C, C++ or Fortune. But how is this possible?
How can Julia be high-performance but also high-level at the same time? What makes Julia a Julia?
Well, what makes Julia a Julia is the idea of multiple this patch. Multiple this patch is the concept
where function code is resolved by looking at the types of every single argument involved.
So let's explore this with this example. Here I define a function add,
it takes to object and something together, and I call add with two different types,
first with just integers and second with floats. So let's look at what this produces.
Here is the output of add and Julia. So first we have add a function with one method,
I'm going to explain this in a second, and then we have our return value is 12 and 12.0.
What we cannot see here is that Julia has specialized code for the two different
function codes for integers and for a floating point. Let's make this more explicit by specifically
providing a new method for the case with floating point. So here now I have an add function specifically
for floating point. Instead of taking a plus b, this returns a exponent b, let's call this.
And what we can see here is that now we have two methods. So we add a new method to the same function.
This is a method that is specifically for floating points. And instead of having the value 12,
we have 100. And this is where the trick lies. Julia compiles the most specialized version that
can be compiled. So version with integers, versions with floats. And in this compiling is an
actual completion with LVM with optimization and so on. This is just ahead of time completion.
So as the Julia knows the type of function is compile if it's not compiled already, and then it's
used. When types are stable and well inferred, this can lead to code that is as performant or comparable
to see and fortune. So this is what makes Julia Julia multiple the spot with just ahead of time
completion of highly efficient code. So now what makes EMAX EMAX? Well, in my opinion what makes EMAX
EMAX is interactivity, extensibility, and community. And I claim the Julia has the same three.
And in interactivity, extensibility, and community are three key pillars for Julia.
More specifically, Julia encourages a repel driven introspective and interactive workflow.
It's largely open to extension and modification. To the point that most of Julia is written in Julia.
And Julia is a thriving and welcoming community with lots of packages. So let me showcase a little
bit of this repel driven introspective interactive workflow with the hope that the commonalities
with EMAX will emerge naturally. So let's start by opening a Julia repel here. I have a Julia
repel. Let me give you a tour of the Julia repel. So the repel comes with lots of useful feature
from a shell to a package manager. So for example, let's add the random package.
Yeah, I have the random package. I can look at what's inside. We have statistics with random
in this particular environment. The environments are fully declarative. So here we have the dependencies
with this environment. And I can explore and this manifests the specific versions you're used.
So we have a shell. We have a package manager. And then we have a very powerful help system.
So for example, I can ask for help for length. And here we can see we have what the help for length.
Lots of information about how to call length, the expected return values, examples.
And now you can probably start seeing that this is not the different from calling length. So this is
the output for length or for help for length in EMAX. So we have help and we can do more. We can even
look at the source code for length. So now what we can see here is that now what we cannot see
because this soon zoomed in because the font size is huge. But in this page here we can see the
implementation of length is this line here in the middle. Or is this few lines here in the middle.
And as you, or let's do this again, as we can see here at the bottom, what we're looking at,
this is the source code of Julia. We can change this. There's even a macro edit if you want to
if you want to change. Thanks. And yeah, I used the word macro. Julia supports
meta programming. And actually meta programming is one of the key features in Julia. It's used
extensively in the core, but it's also used extensively in packages. Both to extend the Julia
ecosystem and function all that is, but also to develop full domain specific languages.
Some of the useful macros are, well, I don't know, like time. Here we have built-in
big z performance tool in Julia. And I want to showcase more introspection macros. But for that,
I'm going to do slightly different. I'm going to open a file example.jl where I define a function,
or our function add. There was an master's, and I'll go back to that in a second. So now I'm going to
include this file, and I can call my function add. One, two, and we get three. And now what I can do
is this, but I can look at what code gets compiled when I call when I call one plus two. And here,
now we can see that there is some integer stuff. But if I make this floating point, now the
compiled code changes. Now maybe, uh, assembly code is a little bit too hard to read. So I can look at
the LVM IR representation. In this case, we can see that there is promotion. The promotion will
probably go away if I make everything float. So this with f add, floating point add for a double,
but we can also look at the, uh, Julia lower representation after the abstract syntax produced.
The reason I put this in a file is because now what I can do is I can change this. And now,
one and two will be two. So this, to me, is very reminiscent of how our work in Amax,
where there's a global state that I can access and modify anytime with no restrictions. And this
happens in Julia too. Typically, we don't want to modify functions that are in other packages,
or there are in base, but we can do that. For example, I can change what is a plus for integers.
And if I change what is plus and make it so that any two integers return zero, well, I can do this.
This will break Julia because, well, Julia's built in Julia. So if we break this, uh, well, nothing will
work, but I can do that. This, to me, is one of the signs of the powerful introspective and powerful
interactive type workflows that Julia enabled. Finally, I want to talk about the general registry.
This is the equivalent of Malpa. It comes with, with Julia, but this is very akin to Malpa. It's
built upon Git essentially. It's collaborative. It's relies heavily on GitHub GitLab. It's
heavily automated and comes with lots and lots of tools and packages. What's beautiful about all
these tools and packages is that in the same way many of Emacs packages just play nicely with
Trader without any input from the developers. The same is true for Julia packages. The Julia
packages are highly composable, so two developers can develop two distinct packages that end up
playing nicely together for free because of the intrinsic structure and tristic way Julia objects
are built. So with all of this, I also want to mention that the community in addition to having
all these packages is it's highly active, highly collaborative. The community meets regularly
on places like Slack as opposed to the Emacs community that I'd say maybe means I'm right at it.
So with all of this, I want to thank you for your attention. Enjoy Emacs. Enjoy.
Julia.